in spring 2019 Betsy DeVos proposed the
education freedom scholarships a major
school choice plan that would provide 5
billion in dollar-for-dollar federal tax
credits for contributions to state
approved scholarship granting
organizations critics pounced and even
some on the right are skeptical about
federal involvement in private schools
but this proposal tries to walk a
tightrope balancing valid desires to
avoid federal overreach while still
supporting school choice first this
approach makes states take charge of
their own programs
it leaves Treasury to oversee the
federal tax credit and avoids creating a
new program to be run by the Department
of Education second it can help with the
main challenge facing most state school
choice programs and tax credit
scholarships in particular there are low
funding levels this federal tax credit
could safely encourage another source of
funds private donations to make
scholarships of a reasonable size large
enough to adequately help them mostly
low-income families they serve balancing
these two interests is a tricky path but
this proposal could be a good first step
do you think the education freedom
scholarships are a legitimate way to
promote school choice let us know in our
poll also let us know what other topics
you'd like our scholars to cover in 60
seconds and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI